Lo que voy a hacer en este video es escribir
las expresiones algebraicas
que representan lo que se establece
en los siguientes enunciados.
El primer enunciado es,
la suma de -7 y la cantidad 8 veces "x".
Tenemos la suma, así es que va a aparecer
un signo de más aquí, de -7...
-7 al cual le vamos a sumar, la cantidad 8 veces "x",
la cantidad 8 veces "x",
que también podemos escribir como "8x", -7 más "8x", esto representa la suma de -7 y la cantidad 8 veces "x".
Hagamos el siguiente.
Toma la cantidad -3 veces "x"...
-3 veces "x", y luego súmale 1...
y luego súmale 1.
La cantidad, -3 veces "x" la podemos escribir
como "-3x" y luego le sumamos 1, es decir más 1.
Hagamos ahora -6...
-6 más...
vamos a escribirlo aquí...
-6 más el producto de -1 y "x"...
el producto de -1 y "x",
que lo podemos escribir como -1 por "x",
"-1x" que es igual a "-x".
Esto lo podemos escribir como -6 más "-x",
lo cual es exactamente igual,
esto es equivalente a, -6...
-6 menos "x".
Y así hemos concluido.